very good morning to you thanks so much
for joining us this morning on Sky News
breakfast and we're just talking there
about the rail strike so I just wonder
if I can ask you uh quickly a question
about that at the rmt on strike today do
you think that they should put the
latest offer from the rail companies to
a ballot of their members they did that
with the network rail deal do you think
that the rmt should should ask their
members what they think of this one look
you know they have to deal with that
because we all want the rail strikes to
come to an end you know it's not for me
as a labor politician to tell unions how
to the detail of negotiation and
micromanage that but what I do think is
that we really really need these strikes
to come to an end because our country
needs to be able to move on we need to
recover it's not good for people to have
to take strike action nobody wants to do
it and I would really say to the
government that they need to negotiate
properly they need to make sure that
they do all they can to end these
strikes and frankly this is dragged on
and on and it's not good for people who
want to get to to you know it's not good
for people given the big events that
we've got Eurovision today and others
and it's not good for those people
feeling feeling forced to take
industrial action either
okay meanwhile Society is due to make a
speech today uh we're told that he's
going to say that he will offer voters a
radical election Vision that goes
further and deeper than Tony Blair's and
uh he says it'll be like Clause 4 on
steroids what does that mean what's that
going to look like in terms of policy
well people will remember in 1997 the
country had been through 18 years of a
Tory government and you know our Public
Services were on their knees and labor
came in and reformed the country we
rebuilt the NHS and schools and people
will know that that you know people
thought that that couldn't happen and
there was that same feeling of
hopelessness in the 90s too but now it's
actually a bigger challenge because not
only have the Tories yet again ruined
our public services and waiting lists
which we thought we had tackled have
re-emerged but also we've got the global
challenge we've got a war on the
continent we've got the need to take
action on climate change and we've also
got a problem not of unemployment in
this country but of people not able to
earn enough and not able to make
progression and get really good jobs so
actually those challenges are different
and they're bigger in some ways and
that's why we need a labor party that
has changed itself after our historic
defeat of 2019 but listens to the
country and the public and is that
vehicle for their hope but when you talk
about radical change what does that mean
I mean what are the specifics What
policies will change what can voters
expect that's going to be different from
labor well you know that we have set out
some immediate policies particularly on
schools and hospitals to make sure that
we can get more staff into the NHS and
identified money in order to do that but
take take this issue of employment where
the Tories say and Rishi sunak was
actually called out
for telling ontrusion on telling the
wrong story in the House of Commons
about it that the Tories will say that
we've conquered unemployment but
actually around the country we've got
too many people in low paid work that's
not offering them a good future it's not
offering them progression we want to
change the way that job centers work so
that we get those good jobs from the
energy transition for example we get get
better jobs in the new industries of the
future but also we offer people real
help and support to get those better
jobs and that's not just about tackling
the old problems or doing things in the
way that we have it's about changing
public services so that they really help
people be ambitious and move on and move
up in life
because kusama is talking about Clause 4
on steroids like I said but but what can
you point to so far that that
demonstrates practically a level of
radicalism that comes close to Tony
Blair's
well I think if you look at the
challenge that we faced after
2019 our worst result in uh you know so
many years since 1935 I think and then
you look at how care pulled out
anti-Semitism by its roots fundamentally
changed how the labor party was working
so that we could deal with the problems
that we had internally
then you look at the recent local
election results where we took over 500
new Council seats Tories losing more
than a thousand I think you can see the
results but you know we do need to go
further because the challenges our
countries our country is facing are big
and that's why I say whether it is in
employment making sure that people
really can get much better jobs in the
future or whether that is in schools
helping families have a breakfast club
in every primary school so that we know
that parents have better options about
the choices of jobs that they have we
have got to really think about where our
country is going in the future and be
that vehicle for Change and hope that is
so desperately needed
if you're talking about radical change
does it seem does it mean more
backtracking by kirstama on previous
pledges we have seen him reverse
promises that he's made on tuition fees
just in the last week or so and the
nationalization of utilities as well
just for two examples
what we've done is say that all our
policies must be properly costed and I
think that's the right thing for any
responsible party that's hoping to go
into government to do actually if you
look at the changes that we're proposing
it's about thinking about where we want
our country to be in the future take for
example investment in changing our
Energy Mix that's needed for climate
change but it's also needed to make the
make sure that people's family finances
are more sustainable we want to insulate
people's homes just to give one example
because that will be the kind of change
that will help with costs now but also
will give people better jobs and change
the way people live into the future so
you know for me it's about making sure
that the labor party is that vehicle for
Change and hope and that we're not sort
of having an internal argument but we're
thinking about where the country is
headed and how we can put down a more
sustainable footing for the future
and and I'm reading the papers this
morning that labor plans to restrict
bosses sending their employees any
Communications out of ours is that
something you're pushing through on
explain that to us
so what we want is for people to have a
good quality of life at work and I think
lots of people want to make sure that
flexible working is actually means that
good quality of work you know we've all
got used to very different ways of
working whether that is zoom and you
know having many more remote meetings
and the change that that means or
whether that is you know the fact that
we all live with our smartphones all the
time we've just got to make sure that
those
um guard rails are there to make sure
that people's quality of life is good
because you know all the research and
economic analysis says that if you've
got people with a sense of autonomy and
dignity at work they're far more
creative and Innovative and they're able
to find new ways of doing things and
make our economy more productive more
profitable so it's about putting those
rules in place to make sure that
everybody can get the most out of life
at work people want to have good jobs
they want to achieve something in their
life at work and that's what we're
thinking about how do you make those
jobs really as good as they possibly can
be well paid well skilled and also that
sense of you know a real sense of
achievement and autonomy
Alison McGovern Shadow employment
secretary thanks very much indeed for
your time this morning